researchers have adapted a miniature
alga you're probably more familiar with
as a dietary supplement spirulina
pratensis and turned it into a tiny
swimming robot for decades engineers
have tried to build medical robots that
can deliver drugs or perform surgery
inside the human body but powering these
tiny machines has been a challenge since
most potential fuels are toxic to the
body and even if you can get them moving
how do you steer in this case
researchers turn to magnetism the team
developed a one-step method for
magnetization by dipping millions of
spirulina into iron oxide nanoparticles
they're dipped for certain durations to
allow the algas natural fluorescent glow
to remain visible under fluorescence
microscopes now a magnetic field can
move the magnetized spirulina through a
body the spiral shape of spirulina makes
it ideal for this type of control by
manipulating it with magnets it can be
twirled forward or backward when the
magnetic micro swimmer gets too deep for
its fluorescence to be detected then the
team can rely on magnetic resonance
imaging to track it the microbots
degrades in hours or days depending on
the thickness of the magnetic coating
yet doesn't damage most cells with one
exception cancer cells
when exposed to the microbots here in
red only 10% of cancer cells lasted 48
hours tests indicate spirulina produces
a compound that's toxic just to cancer
cells even though researchers have
created a mini bio hybrid that can be
steered and tracked there's a lot more
work to be done before these tiny
machines are ready for doctors to use
next the team will try to get the
microbots to carry and deliver cargo
such as life-saving drugs
[Music]
you